the general was regarded as one of
Keaton's less good comedies at the time
I cannot understand why a mild Civil War
comedy not up to Keaton's best standards
was what one of the magazine's said and
now it's probably the most the best
loved silent comedy you can think of it
was a problem for Keaton in that he'd
spent so much money and put so much
effort into it and I think it was one of
the elements that led his producer
Joseph skank to decide to sell him to
MGM which was very sad as we all know
but why it stood the test of time it is
probably and this is a very strange
thing to say it's probably the most
authentic film about the Civil War to
look at it looks like moving photographs
by Matthew Brady the the uniforms the
the vehicles the everything about it is
absolutely perfect
I remember Keaton's said to his crew
make it so authentic it hurts to be
interviewed a woman who was a little
girl at the time and she said that when
the locomotive crashed through the
bridge they didn't realize that it was a
dummy playing the engineer and they all
screeched when they saw this apparently
poor fella in the in the cab and then
there was a whale from the whistle as it
went underwater which added to the
tragedy of the moment they really
thought the poor man had gone